[Musique]
Jérémy Zimmerman. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Ah ouais.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement s'il vous plaît ?
Déjà, je sais pas pourquoi tu me vous
vois, ça fait bizarre. Bon, vas-y.
Euh ben je suis Jérémy Smirman. Voilà,
je c'est moi. Je j'ai été pendant un
temps euh porte-parole d'une
organisation qui s'appelle la Quadrature
du Net que j'ai fondé il y a une dizaine
d'années.
Euh j'ai depuis une quinzaine d'années
euh milité pour les logiciels libres,
pour leur défense et leur promotion.
Euh et je suis je me demande même
pourquoi je suis là, tu vois.
Alors, tu es là, je vais je vais dire
pourquoi tu es là. tu fais partie de de
nos tout premiers invités. On se connaît
depuis depuis des années. Et le fait que
tu quittes la quadrature euh que tu
démissionnes,
nous on on s'est senti obligé de
t'inviter parce que tu fais partie de
des murs pratiquement. C'est vrai hein.
Et et euh ta démarche intellectuelle au
sein de la quadrature nous a aussi
beaucoup motivé pour continuer ce qu'on
ce qu'on fait. Et donc voilà.
Bah démissionner, c'est un peu formel,
c'est administratif. C'est juste j'ai
souhaité m'enlever cette étiquette là
pour euh pour continuer aller faire
autre chose. Tu sais, ça nous arrive
tous dans la vie. Un moment, on sait
quelque chose et puis voilà, on va faire
autre chose. Euh donc j'ai énormément de
respect pour la quadrature du net et
tous ceux qui qui y sont. Je leur fait
tous un gros bisou. Euh certains de mes
meilleurs amis euh sont ceux avec qui
j'ai partagé ces moments absolument
formidables. J'ai j'ai passé des moment
une expérience dingue avec avec tous ces
gens-là. Donc c'est juste voilà, il y a
un moment où en fait quand tout le monde
venait me voir en disant "Ah j'adrature
du net." Alors que moi en fait ça fait 4
ans que j'ai lâché mon mon poste à
pleintemps tu vois de représentant, de
porte-parole, coordinateur et cetera. Il
était juste temps de de marquer ça, de
marquer que voilà, si vous voulez parler
à la quadrature du N, vous allez là-bas,
vous voulez parler à moi, vous venez
ici. Mais c'est pas voilà, c'est pas le
c'est pas la de
Alors, revenons aux sources. Pourquoi la
quadrature à l'époque ? Ben à l'époque
parce qu'on était un certain nombre à se
retrouver autour des valeurs du logiciel
libre euh d'un usage de de
l'informatique et des réseaux euh qui
permettait aux gens de de se retrouver,
de réfléchir, de partager, de mettre en
commun, de s'organiser
et que alors qu'on était chacun dans nos
structures autour du logiciel libre, on
s'est dit là il y a d'autres trucs qui
sont en train de se passer. Euh, on
avait euh bataillé sur la transposition
de la directive EUCD, les vieux
souvenirs parlent d'un tank, les moins
de 20 ans tout ça. Euh un projet de loi
qui venait toucher au logiciel libre par
le le copyright euh par le droit
d'auteur qui venait imposer des espèces
de conneries restrictives. Nous, on
était monté au front, on était allé au
parlement, on avait envoyé machin, on
avait passé plein de coups de fil et
cetera, mais c'était une fois sur un
projet. Et à l'époque en fait quand
quand Sarkozy était en train d'accéder
au trône, on s'est dit "On va en chier"
et il est arrivé et il a mis la dopie
sur la table. Et donc on s'est dit voilà
là, il y a besoin de se s'organiser un
petit peu pour aller contrer ce genre de
menace. Mais euh dès le début en fait,
c'était un peu notre expérience, notre
euh notre background comme on dit, vous
avez la traduction simultanée, je crois.
Euh l'idée c'était d'aller sur ces
fronts euh parlementaires législatifs
euh pas parce qu'on croyait
fondamentalement que la loi c'était
l'alpha et l'oméga de tout ce qui se
passait euh dans le monde, mais parce
qu'on avait repéré là des processus
particulièrement euh infects,
un processus de de d'élaboration
qui était particulièrement corrompu, des
lobby industriels qui arrivaient avec
des dossiers dorés sur tranche qui se
retrouvaient boum direct copier qui est
collé sous forme d'amendement des
ministres et des machins ministériels
qui étaient à brasser du vent et qui et
qui copiaclait les trucs des lobby et on
s'était dit à l'époque que c'était
intéressant d'exposer ça pour bâtir une
sorte de de compréhension collective,
une sorte de mémoire politique. Ça a été
d'ailleurs le titre d'un d'un logiciel
qu'on a qu'on a développé pendant un
temps pour garder des traces des
décisions qui étaient prises dans les
parlements. Et donc on s'était dit
voilà, on veut euh on veut donner à
chacun les moyens de comprendre, les
moyens de s'organiser, les moyens de
participer. Donc on a pris comme un
presque comme un outil en fait ces
dossiers législatifs, comme un cas
d'école. Si voilà, si vous voulez
comprendre le monde euh et si vous
voulez comprendre comme les choses
évoluent, regardons l'espace d'un
instant un petit bout de processus
législatif. Donc très vite euh très vite
bon on a un peu fait du bouquin à
l'époque et très vite on s'était
retrouvé au Parlement européen et donc
moi j'ai passé
peut-être 7 ans à naviguer dans les
couloirs du Parlement européen. Au début
je connaissais une personne puis deux
puis trois et de proche en proche
documenter ces processus législatifs à
l'échelle européenne.
Et même bon, il y a plein de trucs qu'on
a fait au milieu de la nuit, bourré, en
se disant "Ouais, c'est cool." Euh un
moment, on a pris un diagramme
improbable venant de la Commission
européenne qui expliquait le processus
législatif européen. Alors machin,
première lecture du truc, première
lecture du bidule,
truc, tu le vois, tu as envie de te te
pendre tellement c'est obscur. Enfin, le
diagramme lui-même explique pourquoi
tout le monde s'en fout en fait de
l'Union européenne. Et nous, on a pris
le machin et on mettait vous êtes ici.
Je passé un quart d'heure sur Wingscape
à faire, tu sais, un cercle comme ça
avec qui vous êtes ici avec un point au
milieu et on le déplaçait sur le
diagramme pour essayer vaguement de
tenter d'expliquer ce qui se passait.
Donc on a fait ça pendant des années euh
puis la quadrature du net c'est devenu
euh c'est devenu une sorte
d'institution, c'est devenu autre chose.
A il y a des salariés, il y a des
membres, il y a un un crédit d'estime
d'image. Euh c'est un devenu un presque
un bon client des médias. Il y a il y a
beaucoup de dossiers aujourd'hui qui
sont traités par la quadrature du NAT.
Euh et moi j'ai juste à un moment
ressenti le besoin d'aller faire autre
chose. Voilà, ça j'ai tu sais parfois on
dit que les vies des gens c'est des
cycles de 5 ans, 7 ans, 10 ans je sais
pas. Moi voilà c'est un cycle, c'est la
fin d'un cycle. Au passage il se trouve
que à force de me retrouver dans les
couloirs du Parlement européen,
de rencontrer bon parfois des gens très
bien,
tu as proposé d'en manger un peu ? Bien
sûr, bien sûr. Là, il s'était vraiment
se trompé de
des noms.
Non, des noms, non, mais des gens viens
notre partie machin là, partie bidule,
partie machin genre.
C'était ma réponse de base.
Tu veux pas marcher quoi ?
Non non non, je non, je soit je cours,
soit soit je suis à l'arrêt, je
contemple je marche pas ou pas. Euh mais
le truc c'est qu'après euh
à la louche une dizaine d'années parce
que avant la quadrature du net, il y
avait la bataille sur les brevets, sur
les logiciels et des trucs et d'autres
trucs. En gros, après une dizaine
d'années à regarder le processus
législatif européen, à voir la
Commission européenne et ses crânes
d'œuf, avoir le Parlement avec ses
commissions parlementaires et ses
trilogues et ses machins, on va même pas
rentrer dans les détails,
bah quelque part, j'ai perdu la foi.
Il y a 10 ans, tu m'aurais demandé bah
alors l'Europe machin, je t'aurais dit
"Oui, l'Europe, le Parlement européen,
l'institution démocratique et tout." On
y va, on y va, on y va. Et à force de
regarder ces machins fonctionn, plus
j'en parlais, plus je me rendais compte
que j'expliquais en fait pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas.
Europe ne fonctionne pas.
Bah si tu regardes le fameux diagramme
du processus dit de codécision,
l'élaboration législative de tout le
monde s'est endormi déjà sur la sur la
chaîne sur la chaîne YouTube. Euh si tu
regardes le processus de codécision, tu
vois, oui, la commission est la seule
qui balance un truc, qui met un truc sur
la table. Ensuite, le parlement est
carburée. Le parlement est démocratique.
Les gens sont élus, machin, il se passe
des trucs. Parlement décide quelque
chose et puis vient le conseil de l'UE.
Le conseil de l'UE, c'est les
gouvernements, c'est les États-membres.
Quand on va parler d'Internet, ça va
être 28 ministres des télécom. Quand on
va parler de glyphosate, ça va être 28
ministres de l'agriculture.
Et le le conseil de LE en fait, c'est le
collégislateur. Comme on a l'Assemblée,
le Sénat qui se renvoie la navette
parlementaire, on a le Parlement et le
Conseil. Et donc ça choque personne ou
alors tout le monde s'en fout que une
bande d'exécutifs
non élu
c'est l'exécutif une bande d'exécutifs
mis dans le même sac se retrouve
législatif séparation des comme on
disait déjà séparation des pouvoirs il y
a pas et cette bande de c'est toi qui
l'a dit non élu du conseil de l'UE a
systématiquement le dernier mot après le
Parlement européen. Parlement peut
décider oui on va la machin si derrière
les Étatsmembres disent on en veut pas
on en veut pas on se retrouve en seconde
lecture. Le parlement dit mais si on en
veut quand même. Et les évidemment
disent ben non on en veut pas. Et à la
fin d'une éventuelle 3ème lecture qui
arrive tous les 36 du mois le c'est les
Étatsmembres qui décident de mettre le
truc à la poubelle. Et donc pour avoir
vécu le truc pendant 10 ans du début à
la fin, mais al le le diagramme je l'ai
écumé comme les sept mères, arrivé à
cette conclusion, mais en fait ça peut
pas fonctionner démocratiquement ce
merdier et me retrouver avec le le
statut de personne publique qui m'est un
petit peu tombé sur le coin de la gueule
à me retrouver dans des interviews, des
trucs et des machins et des des
conférences et trucs à me mordre
l'intérieur de le de la de la bouche
parce que si j'exprimais un peu trop mon
opinion là-dessus
J'avais un discours qui commençait
presque à à
être le le le calque du discours des
eurosceptiques genre François Linot.
Ben le truc c'est que je suis ni
nationaliste ni fasciste pour te dire
les frontières je je m'en cogne. Je suis
plutôt contre.
Non non mais qu'est-ce que tu me dis ?
Je sais même pas qui c'est. Voilà, on
s'en fout. C'est même pas une question
de nom ou de parti ou de truc et de
machin. Je me rendais compte que
ma vision de l'Europe commençait à
coïncider avec celle de ceux qui étaient
contre l'Europe parce qu'ils étaient
pour les nations, contre l'autre, pour
la violence. Et je me suis dit non mais
voilà là il faut que je faut que
j'arrête, faut que j'aille faire autre
chose. Au passage physiquement j'ai
comme on dit burnout. Il y a mon corps
qui m'a dit hut, tuarrêtes ? Donc j'ai
arrêté et euh pendant que la quadrature
devenait autre chose, se structurait
avec pour objectif de euh quelque part
de générer moins de de douleur pour ceux
qui la qui la font avancer,
euh ben moi, je suis allé faire autre
chose. J'ai pris un petit peu de
distance, j'ai pris mon temps, j'ai j'ai
pris le temps de me de me remettre en
place. C'est c'est le fait que tu crois
en l'Europe et que tes tes désillusions
on ont pris le contrôle de ta pensée.
Face à
Non, contrôle enfin contrôle de ma
pensée vient malin celui qui pourrait
dire d'où il vient. Euh non, enfin fini
ta question. Pardon.
Donc donc l'Europe l'Europe ça
fonctionne pas en fait.
Écoute, sur les sujets sur lesquels j'ai
uvré pendant 10 ans, on a remporté des
batailles euh des victoire phénoménale.
Attends, attends, attendsends attends.
Non non, tu pas dire ça, tu pas ce qu'il
a fait pour ceux qui voient pas Bruno,
il était
fait comme on a dit pour le chèque. Euh
il était en train de me faire non, on a
remporté des victoires qui étaient
inimaginables à l'époque
rouble.
On on a fait péter le high score du
nombre de coups de fil entrant dans le
Parlement européen autour du paquet
Télécom. On a fait adopter par 88 % du
Parlement européen un truc qui dit "Les
droits et libertés des utilisateurs
d'internet ne peuvent être que par une
décision préalable du juge au moment où
la France était en train de faire son
adopie. 88 % du parlement. Bon Sarkozi
était le président du conseil de lieu.
Donc ils ont fait quoi ? Ils ont pris
silit
on s'en fout.
On a remporté cette victoire contre
l'ACTA. Quand je dis on, c'est pas nous
la quadrature du net, c'était une espèce
de de coalition informelle, un réseau de
réseau au travers de l'Europe et du
monde. On avait des amis polonais,
japonais euh australiens, américain
toujours
que que j'ai toujours bien sûr, mais qui
faisait partie de cette de cette de ce
mouvement où on a défoncé un accord
commercial qui a été négocié par 39 pays
dont les 27 à l'époque de l'UE où
pendant 4 ans tout le monde nous a dit
mais c'est des clown, ça marchera
jamais. À la fin, on a gagné 12 contre
un.
Donc on on a quand même vachement secoué
le cocotier. Il y a quand même des
moments, il y a des technos de la
Commission européenne, je j'ai
l'impression, j'imagine qu'il do encore
parfois se réveiller au milieu de la
nuit
internet. Oh mon dieu ! Non non non,
c'est pas c'est pas moi. C'était c'était
vraiment une espèce de réseau de réseau.
Et donc on a quand même secoué un
certain nombre de cocotiers
mais au bout du compte il y a toujours
le machin qui revenait par la fenêtre
une fois qu'on l'avait chassé par la
porte. On a on a beau se débarrasser une
fois, deux fois, trois fois des fameuses
mesures techniques que doivent utiliser
les opérateurs d'Internet pour enlever
les contenus illégaux et autres
formulations qui qui ouvrent la porte à
la censure généralisée. À chaque fois
qu'on le dégageait, dans les 6 mois, une
nouvelle consultation publique sur Nani
Nana. Euh il y a il y a il y a il y a
une fois où on a on a fait en sorte
qu'il y ait 1500 personnes qui répondent
à une consultation publique de lieu.
Alors que d'habitude tout le monde s'en
cogne. Ce qui faisait que les les
individus étaient les les premiers à
répondre avant même l'industrie.
Mais quel que soit le résultat de la
consultation, on sait très bien ce
qu'ils allaient faire derrière et ce
qu'ils allaient faire derrière, c'était
la même. Donc il y a un moment, tu vois,
c'est c'est cisif, tu sais, tu vides le
verre, il se remplit et
la bonne tienne, tu vois. Moi je un
moment je suis allé
je suis allé boire ailleurs quoi.
Tu demandes quoi ? Tu demandes plus de
souveraineté ? Tu demandes quoi ? Est-ce
que est-ce qui est-ce que si on récupère
un peu plus de souveraineté ça permettra
de faire avancer correctement les débats
? Pas
direct. Il y va la souveraineté. Ta
tata.
C'est la c'est les arguments des gars
c'est les arguments des gars qui est en
face. Non, alors attends, bon déjà
souveraineté, c'est un de ces ces mots
valises qui veulent dire euh tout et et
son contraire. Et puis surtout pour
commencer, moi je demande rien comme je
t'ai dit. Je je sais pas vraiment
pourquoi je suis là parce que
aujourd'hui je représente rien ni
personne que moi-même. Tu vois, tu
m'avais interrogé en tant que
porte-parole de la quadrature du net
machin. Bon, il y avait une position que
je te je te je venais te livrer. Euh
c'était à moitié ce que je pensais moi
et puis ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on ce
qu'on pensait dans ces ces ces
discussions collectives. Mais là
vraiment c'est c'est juste moi. Donc je
demande rien. Je demande rien à
personne.
Moi, je suis je suis allé prendre de la
distance, je suis allé réfléchir,
je suis allé regarder le monde un petit
peu différemment.
Il y a ce biais qu'on a tous, je crois,
que quand tu fais quelque chose pendant
1 an, 5 ans, 10 ans, tu sais, on dit
quand tout ce que tu as, c'est un
marteau, tous les problèmes ressemblent
à un clou. Donc il y a un moment où tu
te retrouves avec un mode de pensée. Tu
es administrateur réseau, tu vas tout
voir en mode d'administration réseau. Tu
es réalisateur, tu vas tout voir en mode
de cadre de lumière, de machin. Tu es
politique, tu vas tout voir en matière
de d'influence, de pouvoir, de projet de
loi et cetera. Donc moi, j'ai eu ce
besoin pour moi, et je dis pas que c'est
ce qu'il faut pour le monde, mais j'ai
ce besoin pour moi de prendre de la
distance, de prendre du recul, de de
remettre en question des choses dont
dont j'étais convaincu et et de prendre
le temps du temps et de prendre le temps
de la réflexion,
prendre le temps de l'érance. Donc je
demande rien à personne.
Euh je souhaite
à bon nombre d'entre nous euh d'avoir
peut-être par des privilèges similaires
au mien ou par la le le le le un
concours de circonstan d'avoir
l'occasion
de réfléchir, de prendre la distance et
de penser à ces choses. Voilà, avec un
petit peu de recul. Maintenant, tu me
parles de souveraineté.
Je vais te parler de Brexit.
Oh, il me parle de Brexit. Tu tu je vais
aller boire une bière en face pendant
que tu parles de Brexit.
Question d'internet, est-il possible de
réformer l'Union européenne ?
Parce que Mais c'est quoi la
souveraineté ? C'est la souveraineté des
États-nation ? C'est la souveraineté des
institutions ? Ou c'est la souveraineté
des individus ? Ou c'est la souveraineté
de nos corps ? Tu vois tu qu'est-ce que
tu veux dire par souveraineté ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire ?
Voilà qu'il qui c'est qui ?
Euh la question d'internet, c'est est-il
possible de réformer l'Union européenne
pour qu'elle devienne démocratique ?
Quelle conséquence sur l'Union
européenne ? Si elle se défait.
Bon,
frexite ou bon, il a bondo internet
hein, franchement. Euh
non mais euh écoute, pour réformer l'UE,
il faut réformer les traités
constitutifs de l'UE.
Donc je sais pas si tu te rappelles, on
a eu en 2006, je crois un vote sur un
traité qui était un projet de
constitution européenne où 55 % des
Français ont dit non.
Dans les années qu'on suivi, le truc
quasiment la virgule près est revenu et
s'appelait traité de Lisbonne parce que
les Étatsmembres ensemble ont décidé, on
va faire un nouveau traité et ce traité
a été adopté.
Donc ça c'est les traités constitutifs
de lieu. Il y a eu le traité de
Lisbonne, il y a eu le traité de
Mastrich, il y a eu le traité de Rome et
cetera. Et donc c'est utiliser le terme
constitution mais c'est en gros l'épines
dorsales
de l'Union européenne. Ces traités là
pour les modifier, il faut l'unanimité.
des Étatsmembres, les mêmes qui laissent
rien passer au Parlement, qui soi
contraire à leurs intérêts nationaux
négociés, il faut l'unanimité. Donc un
problème simple, le Parlement européen,
il est à Bruxelles, tu sais, puis il a
Strasbourg aussi, c'est Chirak et Elmou
Cole, je crois, qui avait décidé ça à
l'époque. Quel beau symbole. Strasbourg,
l'amitié franco-allemande, les 12
Shiraak ou pas Mitéran ? Non, non,
Chiraak,
je sais pas, peut-être, peut-être. Bref,
c'était pour le symbole. C'était beau,
c'était bien, tout le monde était
content. À l'époque, il y avait 12
étatsmes. Aujourd'hui, il y en a 28. Le
centre géographique de l'Union
européenne, je crois qu'il est quelque
part entre l'Allemagne et la Pologne
aujourd'hui. Donc tous les députés
européens aillent une semaine par mois
de Bruxelles à Strasbourg, en fait, ça
fait chier tout le monde. Strasbourg,
c'est une petite ville très jolie, très
bonne choucroûe, bonne bière et cetera.
Mais 99 % des gens du Parlement
européen, ça les gonfle d'aller de
Bruxelles à Strasbourg avec des malles
remplises de documents qui se perdent en
chemin. Les hôtels sont pleins à
craquer. Des assistants parlementaires
sont cinq dans des chambres doubles. Les
taxis en a 800 à Strasbourg pour 5000
personnes qui viennent travailler une
semaine par mois dans ce machinlà. Pour
bouger le Parlement européen de
Strasbourg pour dire bon allez, on
arrête les conneries maintenant on reste
à Bruxelles parce que c'est plus
pratique pour tout le monde. Il faut
l'unanimité des Étatsmembres. Donc il
faudrait que la France soit d'accord
mais la France elle voudra jamais
parce que ça apporte du blé à la région
parce que ça truc parce que ça machin.
Donc tu vois sur un problème qui est qui
est à noin, il y a une pétition qui a
été signée par 90 % du Parlement
européen pour dire on veut plus de
Strasbourg, on peut pas. C'est je sais
plus combien genre 23 camions de 12
tonnes qui vont de Bruxelles à
Strasbourg une fois par mois pour porter
les mâles pleines de de papier. Ça fait
aucun sens aujourd'hui. Pourtant ça
changera jamais parce que la France
voudra jamais. Donc maintenant, tu
imagines l'unanimité des États-membres
quand tu as Victor Orban en Hongrie,
quand tu as loi et justice en Pologne,
quand les Italiens, euh les Autrichiens
et toute cette bande de faot qui arrive
au pouvoir en capitalisant sur la la
déliquence des institutions et des
partis politiques, quand est-ce qu'il y
aura une unanimité des Étatsmembres sur
quoi que ce soit dans un futur proche ou
éloigné.
Donc souveraineté machin tout tout. Moi
si tu veux, j'aimerais bien de parler de
la souveraineté des des individus
et comment on fait parce que là je suis
ravi d'être ici tout ça machin mais on a
fait que parler déjà un peu de moi ce
qui m'embarrasse et beaucoup de l'UE des
institutions et des machins. Maintenant
tu sais mes sujets c'est c'est internet,
c'est les ordinateurs, c'est les réseaux
d'ordinateur, c'est le logiciel libre et
les machins comme ça. Donc ça veut dire
quoi la souveraineté des individus ? Ça
veut dire quoi être soi-même ? Avoir la
garantie d'être soi-même, avoir la
liberté d'être soi-même, de de pouvoir
devenir quelque chose, de pouvoir
expérimenter avec des idées, de pouvoir
expérimenter avec soi-même. Ça veut dire
quoi ça aujourd'hui ? Quand dès que tu
commences à réfléchir et que tu appuies
sur une touche de ton clavier, il y a
une entreprise de la Silicone Valet qui
stock sur son disque dur.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
souveraineté ? Quand dans nos poches, on
a des machins qui sont des espions
bourrés de senseur avec deux caméras, un
micro, un truc, un machin que qu'on ne
sait pas contrôler
parce qu'il il comporte cette puce, le
baseband qui est un truc entièrement
propriétaire, fermé, contrôlable à
distance et
personne ne sait ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur.
Et personne ne sait ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur. Tu vois ? Donc, s'il
fallait vraiment parler de souveraineté,
parlons de la souveraineté des individus
et de comment les les machins dans le le
dans dans les Étatsntions, dans les
frontières, les institutions et les
trucs qui sont censés nous représenter
vont pouvoir éventuellement nous aider à
reconquérir cette souveraineté
individuelle qu'on a perdu.
RGPD,
elle est bonne celle-là. Elle est bonne
celle-là.
Pourquoi elle est bonne ?
règlement général, la protection des
données machin machin. Mais encore une
fois, quand tu vois comment les trucs
sont élaborés à Bruxelles, il y a des
exceptions, il y a des trous partout. Il
y a des trous partout dans ce machin. Il
y a une notion dit d'intérêt légitime ou
quand c'est l'intérêt légitime du
processeur de données, alors il a pas à
mettre en œuvre les obligations qui sont
les siennes. Il y a cette notion de
consentement où vous avez tous vu, tu
cliques un site web, on te dit "Bon ben,
c'est cool hein, tu es chez nous, tu
consens." Oui. Non. Et si tu cons pas,
tu te casses. Alors, peut-être qu'un
jour une cour de justice va dire que
oui, machin, malin, mais ça va être
peut-être dans un an, peut-être dans 2
ans, puis il y aura un appel et
peut-être 3 ans et peut-être 5 ans. En 5
ans, les lobby industriels, ils ont le
temps de faire écrire trois nouvelles
législations.
Les histoires de Télécom, le paquet
Tellécom, c'est quasiment tous les ans
qu'il y a un nouveau projet de loi qui
arrive à Bruxelles. Donc eux, ils jouent
la montre. Ils ont un texte qui a un AMA
incompréhensible qui génère beaucoup
d'attention. Tu as plein de de juristes,
d'avocats qui sont là. Oui, RGPD machin
là là qui vendent des nouveaux services
de prestation. Mais oui, c'est un
nouveau c'est un super business. Donc
tout le monde est occupé avec ce nouveau
business là,
brasser du vent.
Et pendant ce temps-là, le comportement
des prédateurs des entreprises des
données ne change pas d'un Yota. Et
pendant ce temps-là, la dépendance à
leur service, elle ne fait qu'augmenter
et leur leur le leur pénétration dans
nos sociétés, dans nos institutions,
dans dans nos poches, dans nos modes de
vie devient de plus en plus
irréversible.
Donc je veux pas je veux pas avoir l'air
plus cynique que je ne le suis,
mais pour avoir vu de l'intérieur
comment s'élabord la loi,
pour avoir vu aussi comment elle est
appliquée
et comment les pouvoirs politiques les
uns après les autres
dansent autour du pot et dansent de font
la danse du ventre devant les lobby
industriels et leur donnent le stylo
pour écrire la loi eux-même. Moi, je me
dis que notre salut il viendra pas de la
loi.
Bah d'où ? Alors,
je te renvoie la question. D'où d'où
viendra alors le salut, c'est peut-être
un grand mot, mais que nos nos façons
de, osons le mot, de résister
et de s'organiser pour résister,
peut-être qu'elles ne passeront pas par
la loi et attendre que le règlement
machin finisse de tomber avec tous ces
trous, avec toutes ces incertitudes,
avec tous ces ces ces ces ces machins
qui seront transposés de 12 façons
différentes. Donc moi, c'est à titre
personnel et même au travers de la
quadrature du net et même d'avant dans
mes mes passages euh militants dans
d'autres organisations avant la
quadrature du net.
Mais ma question fondamentale, c'est
enfin mes questions fondamentales, c'est
un qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de comment on le fait ?
Et euh
ou courge ou et dans quel étagère ?
Mais sérieusement,
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on veut ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on défend ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on prome ? Et comment on
s'organise ? et surtout comment on on
fait ça sans tomber dans une forme de
routine, sans tomber dans des pièges de
devenir les bons clients, d'aller
répondre aux consultations, de faire là
où on nous dit de faire, de nous asseoir
sur la petite chaise qu'on nous a laissé
dans un coin de la salle de réunion
multiakeholder.
Selon toi, selon toi, on va où là ?
Alors alors il se trouve que ma boule de
cristal est en panne aujourd'hui donc
j'aurais bien du mal à prédire l'avenir
mais juste en regardant le le présent un
petit peu.
On a des entreprises transnationales
dont le pouvoir est bien au-delà de
celui des États-nations
qui sont engagés dans des comportements
prédateurs
au sujet de nos données personnelles, au
sujet de nos comportements, au sujet de
nos vies.
Donc des euh
une influence qui s'étend sur des champs
qui vont de la banque à l'assurance, à
l'embauche, de
à la la détermination de de de cibles
pour des frappes de drone. Donc vraiment
à toutes les couches de nos sociétés
et en même temps que le pouvoir de ces
entreprises augmente sur nos vies, on a
des pouvoirs publics qui deviennent des
parodies d'eux- même,
tu vois, genre la République en marche,
espèce de petite PME
de voilà petit non start-up, ça veut
dire PME en fait, mais l'espèce de
petite startup de de novice qui sourit
bien sur un poster. et euh marche bien
non ?
Et qui avance en marche forcée. Bah
attends de voir les les attends de voir
les européennes. Attends de voir si ça
marche bien. On se fait
il y a plus il y a plus un poids lourd
pour pour pour soutenir. Et donc une
bande de une bande de clown comme ça qui
arrive sur une espèce de de de coup de
poker et qui parie sur la déliquais des
partis historiques qui sont plus que
l'ombre d'eux-même
euh et qui en fait ont vendu leur
pouvoir au plus offrant.
Euh donc des pouvoirs publics qui ont
lâché la main
et des entreprises qui sont de plus en
plus puissantes.
Ça fait un paysage dans lequel de plus
en plus de gens ne croient plus dans une
espèce de de de mythologie ambiante que
oui, l'État protège la patrie, que
liberté, égalité, fraternité,
quand on renvoie des des bateaux coulés
en Méditerranée,
qu'on gaze des mémés avec leur sac de
poireau, qu'on va faire des perquises à
4h du matin et à signer à résidence des
des militants politiques,
Euh euh ou qu'on laisse des
suprémacistes se s'armer euh de l'autre
côté de l'Atlantique,
on voit des pouvoirs publics qui
renoncent qu'on passe des contrats avec
des gens qui coupent la tête de certains
journalistes.
L'Arabie Saoudite, mais on peut pourrait
parler de Kaddafi aussi, tu vois. et et
euh
donc euh sans avoir capacité même à dire
où on va déjà essayer de de de
tu vois de souffler
et de regarder où l'on est et d'arrêter
de se voiler la face sur un certain
nombre de choses et de regarder avec un
petit peu de distance, un petit peu de
calme où l'on en est. Ça pourrait
peut-être être un début d'élément de
réponse.
C'est pas trop tard
aux questions comment on s'organise et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait. C'est pas trop
tard pour s'organiser. Il est toujours
trop tard et jamais trop tard. Trop tard
par rapport à quoi ?
Tu vois euh
maintenant le fait est qu'on est de plus
en plus nombreux à chercher des façons
de s'organiser qui vont au-delà
des structures institutionnelles.
Comment ça va ta petite fichesse ?
Je sais pas, tu peux tu peux me
l'obtenir toi. Tu tu peux demander, tu
as des des gens à qui tu peux demander.
J'espère qu'elle est épaisse hein parce
que un jour ça fera, tu vois, ça sera
comme des décorations qu'on affichera
peut-être sur notre sur notre plastron,
j'en sais rien, je je m'en fous.
Mais le fait de se dire que ben là où
quand l'institution a échoué, quand on
ne reconnaît plus l'institution, quand
dans notre tête quelque part, on a on a
fini de destituer l'institution, de la
renverser de son socle et de regarder
au-delà, se demander mais qu'est-ce qui
nous reste à faire ? Est-ce que on a
plus que les yeux pour pleurer et c'est
la fin du monde ? Il y a plus de
République, il y a plus rien. Ou est-ce
qu'au contraire, on n' pas là un un un
un un champ des possibles qui s'ouvre à
nous, un boulevard dans lequel décider
de ce que l'on veut être, de ce que l'on
veut faire, de comment on veut
s'organiser les uns les uns avec les
autres.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on réveille nos
vieux démons ? Rebasculer la table,
qu'on s'énerve un peu ? Je sais pas si
un démon qui dort euh
sert à quoi que ce soit ou bénéficie à
quoi que ce soit.
Un démon que tu réveilles.
Tu m'as déjà réveillé le matin, tu sais
ce que c'est.
Préférz qu'on en parle pas. Et euh je
bon et je vois pas vraiment ce que tu
veux dire par là. Pourrais-tu préciser ?
Bah être révolutionnaire pour appeler un
chat un chat.
Après, révolution, c'est un de ces mots
qui ont été un petit peu
aspiré, dénaturé.
C'est plutôt marespierre.
Non, non, mais c'est pas ça. C'est que
tu vois, on va te dire il y a l'iPhone
12 qui sort, c'est une révolution, tu
vois, il y a le nouveau machin de
Google, c'est une révolution. La
nouvelle freebox, c'est une révolution
machin, c'est une révolution. Euh une
révolution, c'est pas euh
déjà dans l'histoire, les révolutions,
ça a jamais été euh des événements très
très prévisibles, très très euh
très très calculés. Très souvent, c'est
un mélange de d'un petit nombre de gens
qui sont organisés et qui savent plus ou
moins où où ils vont et d'un certain
nombre de conditions historiques. Ils
font qu'un pouvoir en place est devenu
une sorte de de de de scène de théâtre,
un truc en carton qui est prêt à
s'effondrer sous son propre poids.
Donc est-ce que les conditions
aujourd'hui sont réunies pour que le
pouvoir en place s'effondre sur son
propre poids ? Peut-être que c'est les
prochaines élections européennes qui le
diront. Peut-être que c'est autre chose.
Peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui
est pas du ressort des élections qui
nous le dira. Et là, bien malin, celui
qui viendra s'asseoir sur ce fauteuil
plus ou moins confortable avec une bière
plus ou moins tiède
avec du gibolin plus ou moins tiède
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé.
Exactement. Attention les enfants euh
pour te dire qu' qu'il sait ce qui va se
passer. Tu vois donc ces conditions par
définition on n'en sait rien. Euh pour
moi, le le la deuxième partie de de la
question, c'est comment on s'organise et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut ensemble.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du comité
invisible ?
Euh
à part définition, il est invisible,
c'est difficile d'en penser quelque
chose. Euh sur les trois bouquins,
l'insurrection qui vient euh à nos amis
et maintenant euh déjà je recommanderai
la lecture. Je suis pas d'accord avec
tout. L'insurrection qui vient, je l'ai
trouvé un peu un peu brouillon, un peu
adolescent dans dans le style.
À nos amis, j'ai trouvé qui qui posait
de très bonnes bases pour aider ceux qui
souhaitaent regarder le monde
différemment à le faire. de dire par
exemple, moi il y a un truc que j'ai
j'ai gardé d' nos amis de dire qu'en
fait quand on regarde ces ces ces clown
en papier euh qui tiennent les
institutions aujourd'hui, les centres de
pouvoir, ils sont plus là où on a
l'habitude de les voir. Un parlement
avec ses colonnes, sa moquette épaisse,
ses dorures, ses statues, ses machins,
en fait, c'est devenu une sorte de
théâtre et qu'en réalité le vrai pouvoir
aujourd'hui, il est dans
l'infrastructure.
C'est EDF, c'est Areva, c'est Google,
c'est les réseaux de de route, de train,
c'est dans dans les réseaux que se
trouve le vrai pouvoir. C'est le le New
York Stock Exchange.
Et cette analyse, moi je la trouve juste
de dire que à mesure que ces clown ont
laissé le pouvoir leur échapper parce
qu'ils l'ont vendu au plus offrant, et
ben le pouvoir, il s'est retrouvé au
plus offrant. et le plus au franc, c'est
les groupes industriels transnationaux
qui ont eux bâti l'infrastructure
de euh de leur de leur fortune qui
souvent repose sur le la captation de
ressources, voir l'exploitation au sens
propre de ressources. Donc ça pour moi
ça a été important de lire ça dans dans
le dans un de nos amis parce que je
l'avais plus ou moins compris en
côtoyant de loin certains de ces acteurs
mais eux là vraiment ils l'ont formulé
de façon assez implacable. Euh le
dernier euh maintenant, je le trouve
intéressant aussi pour des raisons
différentes. Et là encore, je suis pas
d'accord avec tout. D'ailleurs, la façon
dont il parle des communs et du bien
commun, je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup à
redire mais c'est pas pour autant que je
mettrai le le tout à la poubelle. Et
puis de toute façon, j'ai pas besoin
d'être d'accord à 100 % avec quelqu'un
pour trouver que ce quelqu'un est
intéressant.
Mais dans maintenant, ils apportent là
non plus des clés de compréhension, mais
des clés de
quelque part de de mise en œuvre, des
clés d'action en disant voilà, tu te
sens écrasé dans un monde injuste, tu
vois tous ces machins qui déconnent et
cetera et ben tiens, pense destitution.
Imagine qu'en fait le président bah
c'est plus ah le président de tous les
Français machin bah c'est peut-être
juste un clown un pantin
que le la caisse d'assurance machin que
le la l'assemblée le parlement bidule
machin c'est pas les trucs tricolores,
les dorures et les machins. En fait,
c'est peut-être juste une bande de
glandu qu'on rien compris et juste le
fait dans sa tête d'être capable de se
dire mais en fait ça c'est pas
important, ça permet de regarder au-delà
les désacraliser.
Ben il y a ça dans cette notion de
destitution et je trouvais que voilà
c'était un des trucs intéressants. Bon
alors c'est tu parlais de ma fichesse
tout à l'heure, je sais pas si ça me
faire étiqueté un narcoautonome comment
il disait ultra gauche radical ou
violent je sais pas quoi. Je encore une
fois je m'en fous. Et puis de toute
façon, le comité invisible, c'est une de
mes sources d'inspiration. C'est un des
trucs que je lis. Et voilà, si tu étais
Google, tu saurais tout ce que je lis,
même si j'essaie de me de faire
attention.
Euh donc non, je trouve qu'il y a des
des choses intéressantes partout, même
chez des gens avec qui tu es pas
forcément d'accord.
On en est où la surveillance ? Est-ce
que 1984 était censé être un manuel ?
Comment tu vois le
comment tu vois l'évolution des pouvoirs
politiques ? face
vas-y
1984, c'est évidemment une autre de mes
inspirations. Presque un livre de
chevet, tu vois. Je l'ai lu trois quatre
fois. Je recommande à n'importe qui de
le lire et de le lire en anglais
d'ailleurs. Peut-être le lire une fois
en français et puis ensuite le lire en
anglais parce que le verbe d'orwell est
vraiment
euh maintenant c'est presque un tu vois
c'est presque un poncif, c'est presque
un lieu commun d'invoquer 1984 quand on
va parler de surveillance.
Mais 1984, c'est de la douceur à côté de
ce qu'on vit. Je sais pas si tu te
rappelles Winston Smith, il y a un coin
de sa maison, un petit coin dans lequel
il peut se mettre, il ouvre une latte de
son parquet, il sort un carnet et il
écrit des trucs dedans et Big Brother le
voit pas.
C'est quoi un coin de ta maison où
Google te voit pas aujourd'hui
ou tu vois sans parler des des machins
que les gens mettent dans leur salon
qui écoutent en permanence ? Et c'est 20
% des foyers américains, 13 % en
Allemagne, j'ai vu, qui ont un
dispositif espion, un machin d'écoute
dans leur salon qui écoutent en
permanence ce qu'ils disent.
Ouais, les enceintes connectés aussi le
font, hein.
Euh et les téléphones euh Android ou
Apple ou truc machin euh dans dans
1980, enfin 1984, c'est de la petite
bière à côté. Bon, c'est normal, il l'a
écrit dans les années 30, 40, je sais
plus quelle année il l'a écrit.
On va on va demander ça à la communauté.
Ils vont intern
aidez-moi à ne pas avoir l'air imbécile.
Euh
mais sans aller jusque là, les éléments
pour moi les plus importants en 1984,
c'est pas tant Big Brother et la
surveillance parce que ça, tu vois, on
l'a dit, on l'a répété.
C'est l'autocensure.
C'est l'autocensure mais c'est aussi le
le job de Winston Smith au ministre de
la vérité, au ministère de la vérité.
Et cette notion en 1949.
[Musique]
Ah ouais, je suis un peu tombé loin avec
les années 30 mais voilà.
Winston Smith au ministre de la vérité,
il bosse à mettre à jour la novel
langue. Ça aussi c'est un déponsif qui
vient de 1984. Mais la nove langue,
c'est l'état qui impose les mots à
utiliser.
Et ces mots sont imposés pour
neutraliser le sens
parce que c'est notre projet
et pour neutraliser la capacité à
réfléchir et la capacité à penser.
Alors, on avait beaucoup rigolé, enfin
rigolé jaune à l'époque de la lopsie, la
loi d'orientation et de programmation,
brisortefeu, sarcosi, tout ça, une loi
de je crois 140 articles qui touchaient
40 ou 50 codes différents, une espèce de
fourtout incroyable où il y avait un
amendement qu'on avait surnommé
l'amendement novel langue qui disait
remplace dans tous les textes
législatifs et réglementaires le mot
vidéosurveillance
par le mot vidéo protection.
Donc tu as l'état qui dit maintenant on
ne parle plus de vidéos surveillance
mais on parle de vidéo protection et on
comprend tous pourquoi la surveillance
tout le monde se dit ou là j'ai pas
envie d'être surveillé donc peut-être
que c'est justifié la surveillance de
temps en temps mais moi j'ai pas envie
d'être surveillé alors que protection
tout le monde a envie d'être protégé et
donc on voit comment le le sens des mots
est utilisé pour neutraliser la capacité
à penser
pour discréditer certain
et pour moi c'est vraiment ça le cœur de
1984. Et oui, on est en plein dedans.
George Orwell a été un observateur très
fin des régimes totalitires,
des régimes nazis et des régimes
soviétiques et a observé comment le
pouvoir totalitaire exerçait son pouvoir
sur les individus.
Et et c'est ça, je pense l'héritage
d'Orwell. Beaucoup ont lu dans 1984 une
critique du régime soviétique mais s'est
aussi éminemment inspiré des régimes
fascistes pour écrire son truc. Et donc
aujourd'hui, on est dans une forme de de
est-ce qu'il faut appeler ça un
préfascisme,
un protofascisme ? Est-ce que c'est même
une bonne idée de s'en référer à des
régimes des années 30 et 40 pour décrire
le monde dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
? Franchement, j'en sais rien. Mais la
caractéristique de nos régimes
autoritaires aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'il y a une composante
extrêmement forte d'industrie.
C'est plus juste un taré avec une
casquette, un drapeau, un machin qui va
donner l'espoir en machin, un truc
meilleur parce que tout le monde en a
marre. Mais c'est des tarés dans la
silicone valet.
Pourquoi des tarés ? bah des tarés parce
que si tu regardes la psychologie de
gens comme euh Peter Till ou Elon Musk
ou Eric Schmidt, euh tu vois que ces
gens ont une espèce de de de de bulle
idéologique euh inspiré par Ryan Rand
qui est une espèce de d'individualisme
forcené,
libéral. Euh c'est pas c'est pas libéral
là ce stade. C'est euh c'est c'est euh
c'est psychotique, c'est euh c'est
sociopathe,
c'est libéral à un point où tout le
monde est ton ennemi et il y a que il y
a il y a que toi qui est capable de
d'écraser tout le monde pour pour y
arriver. et euh et que ces gens-là sont
glorifiés, ils ont des agences de de com
euh qui s'assurent de de leur image.
Elon Musk a une agence de com que pour
lui, que pour son image à lui et que
parce que ces gens-là ne sont pas le
gouvernement, les pouvoirs publics et
que le gouvernement nani nanana, eux ils
sont respectés, eux ils sont glorifiés,
on les voit comme
étant
presque des modèles. Et donc quand ces
gens-là impulsent des politiques
publiques
euh et je dis la silicone valet mais il
y a pas y a il y a pas que tu vois
courant au transhumaniste et tout ce qui
va avec
et donc voilà quand ces gens-là les
transhumanistes
voilà quand ces gens-là impulsent des
politiques publiques et que les les
pouvoirs publics en sont réduits à les
suivre en courant en tenant un petit
truc derrière pour essayer de récupérer
les miettes derrière eux euh
ben c'est à la fois quelque part
différent des fascismes des années 30 et
40. encore que dans les années 30, les
groupes industriels ont été les premiers
à faire la promotion des régimes
fascistes parce que eux ils promettait
des gros contrats, une grosse expansion
et euh et voilà toutes les les enfin tu
vois en Allemagne les industries et
automobiles et de l'armement et l'acier
et machin il ils étaient ravis de
l'arrivée de ce ce petit gars avec sa
moustache parce que ça promettait des
jobs et tout
Mais donc là, on voit arriver quelque
chose qui est euh
un peu informe. Le contour est mal
défini. Quand c'est une entreprise qui,
par définition, est transnationale. Elle
a beau voir son siège dans en silicone
vallé. Euh, elle a des conseils
stratégiques qui lui viennent de la
Virginie où se trouvent les espions ou
de Washington où se trouve le Pentagone.
Elle a un siège social en Irlande qui
vend de la propriété intellectuelle à
son siège en France puis va revendre ses
bénéfices à la la filiale néerlandaise,
ce qu'on appelle un Double Irish Dutch
sandwich qui permet à Google par exemple
de faire évacuer 60 milliards de dollars
au Bermud et de payer quasiment aucun
impôt sur les sociétés en Europe.
C'est beau.
Donc ces machins là, ils ont même pas de
de centre. Il y a même pas un endroit où
tu peux tourner le regard et te dire
voilà là là il y a un problème et là
c'est l'ennemi.
On fait quoi alors le constat après le
constat ? Question internet après le
constat qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
solutions ? Alors solution : s'il y en
avais, je serais pas en train de de
boire du gibin en discutant avec toi. Je
serais en train de en train d'y
travailler. Enfin, j'ai j'espère être en
train d'y travailler
parce que d'une part, j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a énormément de choses qui nous
sont volées chaque instant et qu'il faut
reconquérir
de la même façon qu'il faut reconquérir
notre capacité à penser et pour ça, il
faut reconquérir notre capacité à
prendre du recul. Reconquérir, oui, se
venger.
Attends, attends, attends. Oh là là,
attends, attends. E oh, tu m'as posé une
question qui est assez difficile comme
ça. Tu vas me laisser le temps d'y
répondre. Laisse-moi le temps de me
planter en y répondant pour ensuite
aller donc reconquérir sa capacité à
penser, son esprit critique. Donc une
forme de de prise de distance. Pour une
prise de distance, il faut prendre du
temps. Pour prendre du temps, il faut
peut-être s'émanciper de ces injonctions
permanence euh permanente à la à la
rapidité. Tu as tweet contre tweet,
retweet réponse claque, email, réponse
claque pup. Les trucs qui clignotent et
qui te disent que tu es obligé d'être
là, de répondre, de machin où les gens
se s'inquiètent pour toi si après 12h tu
as pas répondu à un SMS.
Tu vois, il faut peut-être apprendre à
reprendre le temps.
Pourquoi tu me regardes comme ça ?
Non, je te regarde comme ça parce que tu
es en face de moi, que tu tiens un micro
et que
et que je m'adresse à toi. Je peux
regarder la caméra mais on m'a toujours
appris qu'il fallait pas faire ça quand
on était filmé. Je sais pas tu en penses
quoi ? Non, si ça va.
Euh donc quelque part peut-être
apprendre à reprendre le contrôle de nos
vies, de notre temps, de nos pensées
et par là peut-être
redécouvrir ou découvrir tout tout court
si on en a été privé assez tôt euh nos
humanités.
le fait d'être un humain en face d'un
autre humain
avec du gibolin ou pas, avec une bonne
assiette de de fromage ou des graines ou
je sais pas quoi, mais ce qui nous ce
qui nous connecte, ce qui nous met en
face et qui n'a pas des ordinateurs en
chemin, des trucs sans les écrans, sans
les claviers, sans les réseaux, mais où
on se sent être les uns avec les autres,
où on se sent en lien, on sent en
solidarité, on se sent en capacité,
on partage de l'expérience ensemble et
de là se demander en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
maintenant
sans tu vois les du passé faisons table
rase et autres slogans éculés
sans pensées préconçues sans
sans vengeance
sans idéologie
on y viendra peut-être je vois même pas
ce que je dire là-dessus mais sans sans
truc préconçu avoir vraiment cette
capacité honnête, presque naïve à se
demander voilà maintenant qu'on est là,
je sais pas, on est faut peut-être pas
le dire, on est on est six dans cette
pièce et ben si on coupait la caméra,
qu'on enlevait les écrans, qu'on se
mettait autour d'une table et on se
demande mais on fait quoi ce soir,
demain, la semaine prochaine, qu'est-ce
qu'on veut pour l'année prochaine, pour
dans 5 ans, pour dans 10 ans ? Donc
retrouver
une capacité à être ensemble en dehors
d'un monde d'injonction à l'immédiateté,
en dehors d'un monde qui nous pompe les
données, qui nous pompent la vie pour
nous contrôler. Et alors, j'ai pas envie
de paraphraser le le le comité invisible
ou des machins comme ça. C'est pas une
question de se rendre ingouvernable,
mais quelque part de s'émanciper d'un
certain nombre de formes de contrôle
qu'on a peut-être
déjà intériorisé. le fait, tu vois, tu
vas parler de Google et dire fuck off
Google à des gens, leur expliquer que
Google c'est cette bande de gens qui au
travers du programme des drones US aide
à identifier et suivre des cibles, que
Google font de l'évasion fiscale à
hauteur de milliards d'euros par an, que
Google c'est la surveillance de masse
et tu leur dis ça, ils sont là. Bah oui
mais Google, tu vois comme dans 1984, on
dit "Mais on a toujours été en guerre
avec le Razi." Tu vois ces mantras qu'on
a tellement entendu qu'on les
intériorisé. Mais Google, c'est Google,
comment tu veux te passer de Google ? Et
ben, il y a Cks, un métamoteur de de
recherche, il y a Open Street Map, il y
a et cetera et cetera. Et donc arriver à
balayer des trucs qui sont devenus
tellement des des certitudes qu'on a on
a on a perdu l'habitude de euh les
prendre en considération ou de les
contester. C'est une partie de la
réponse, je pense à qu'est-ce qu'on
fait. Une deuxième partie de la réponse
avant tu as envie de parler de
vengeance, je sais pas mais
pour vant d'état. Mais non, mais attends
euh enfin avant ça, une autre partie de
la réponse parce que
là, je t'ai fait comme une espèce de de
manifeste analogue en mode on se
retrouve autour d'une table entre
humains sans avoir besoin d'écran et de
machins.
Mais ces écrans et ces machins, ils sont
ils sont déjà là. Ils sont dans nos
vies, ils sont partout là. Si on devait
compter entre ceux qu'il y a dans nos
poches sur la caméra, sur les machins,
voilà, il y a on est 6, il doit y avoir
20 écrans dans la salle. Donc la
question c'est pas tous de les détruire
un par un. Euh et la question c'est
aussi est-ce qu'il y a encore quelque
chose à faire
comme par exemple des interviews de plus
d'une heure sans montage ni coupure ?
Mais dis pas qu'on en a plus d'une
heure.
Là, on approche de l'heure là.
Mince, moi j'ai soif. Euh, reste de la
bière quelque du gib. A plus. Bon euh la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va en
faire de tous ces écrans ? Il y a
certains qui sont véritablement devenus
nos espions, nos ennemis et ceuxl il
faut être capable de les identifier et
peut-être oui de s'en séparer.
Peut-être de les de les de les pirater,
de les hacker, de les les bidouiller
pour en faire quelque chose d'autre.
Maintenant la question c'est comment
comment on utilise des écrans ? Comment
aujourd'hui on peut utiliser des
ordinateurs ? tu me vois venir avec mes
gros sabots 150 m de long. Euh la
question du logiciel libre,
c'est un projet politique qui a 30 ans
euh et c'est un projet politique
qu'on a en quelque sorte considéré comme
comme acquis. Tu vois, il y a 15 ans, on
se battait pour le logiciel libre pour
en parler pour que les gens le
comprennent et en parlent. Et là quelque
part, il y a quand même une sorte de de
lassitude. Mais le paysage a aussi
évolué. L'idée au cœur du logiciel
libre, c'est que si on ne se garantit
pas le contrôle des machines
collectivement,
alors les machines vont nous contrôler
ou les mecs qui contrôlent les machines
évidemment.
Et donc
la la façon de de comprendre ces
questionsl, elle a aussi évolué au fil
du temps. Et il y a peut-être là aussi
un ou deux wagons qu'on aurait raté,
voire même un train qu'on aurait raté.
Euh parce que la question du logiciel,
elle s'est déportée vers le matériel.
Sans entrer dans les détails techniques
chiants. Le le firmware euh je sais même
pas comment on appelle ça en bon
français. En gros, le logiciel qui est
niché sur le hardware, sur le matériel
et qui est initialisé quand on allume
l'ordinateur, c'est un truc où Richard
Stalman a commencé à en parler il y a 15
ans en disant il y a un vrai problème
là. On é tous oui Richard tu es bien
gentil mais bon on a pas le temps de
s'emmerder avec ça
Jésus.
Et il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plus vraiment de limite entre ce qui est
logiciel et ce qui est matériel. que tu
allumes un bout de matériel, il va
charger un bout de logiciel dans le
matériel puis ensuite charger un bout de
logiciel qui va appeler un autre bout de
logiciel dans le matériel et que le truc
là on est complètement largué et que si
tu essayes d'utiliser GN Linux Debian
sans logiciel propriétaire dans ta
Debiane, il y a 99,9 % de chance que tu
fasses ça sur du matériel dont tu as
perdu le contrôle parce qu'il contient
dans son dans ces puces du logiciel qui
est propriétaire et qui la plupart du
temps est là pour t'espionner. Et le
paroxisme de ça, c'est les architectures
d'Intel, truc qui s'appelle le
management engine. On a tous besoin de
management, bien sûr. Euh c'est un truc
qui permet, n'est-ce pas, dans le monde
de l'entreprise de faciliter à distance,
bidu machin. C'est un ordinateur dans
l'ordinateur. Et ça c'est depuis quelque
chose comme 2005 ou 2006 que tous les
ordinateurs équipés de processeur Intel
contiennent le machin sur lequel tu vas
travailler et un ordinateur dans
l'ordinateur qui peut être activé à
distance.
C'est la Bague d'or universel. Voilà,
c'est beau,
c'est beau, c'est plutôt pas mal fait.
On sait depuis quelques temps qu'il y a
le système d'exploitation minix à
l'intérieur de ces machins là. Ce qui
est drôle parce qu'il a été écrit par
Enju Tanenbom qui était le mentor de
Linus Torvals,
des loops de loops de loops. Donc là,
j'ai pas de solution toute faite, mais
se poser la question du logiciel libre
en terme éthique, en terme
philosophique, mais aussi en terme
pratique et ce de mettre à jour sa
vision de ce que doit être une
informatique libre. Une informatique
libre, c'est pas euh lire trois fois la
GPL et se battre machin. C'est pas
suivre un dogme. C'est pas brûler un
cierge devant une image de Saint
Ignusius. L'informatique libre, c'est
une utilisation des ordinateurs qui
permettent aux individus de se libérer,
de s'émanciper, de contrôler leur vie
plutôt qu'être à la mercie d'intérêt
prédateur qui soit industriel ou
étatique. Et là, j'ai l'impression
quelque part qu'on a un petit peu, je
vais pas dire, lâché l'affaire, mais en
tout cas perdu du terrain. Gravement
perdu du terrain
parantise.
pas parfait néantise. Écoute, regarde le
nombre de sujets qui nous sont tombés
sur la gueule au cours de ces 10
dernières années. Nous, on est arrivé
machin quadrature du net et tout dopi,
copyright machin depuis regarde la
neutralité du net, regarde les
équipements qui sont collés au cœur du
réseau, regarde la surveillance de
masse, regarde le le filtrage, tu vois.
Regarde le le le
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on était on
était on nous a appelé cus dans un
garage. On a rarement été plus de de
cinq à être à temps plein à faire ce
genre de machin. Donc c'est pas qu'on
soit fait dépasser par les événements
tant que les événements eux-mêmes sont
vraiment dépassants quoi. Donc là aussi,
prendre un peu de recul, mettre à jour
notre vision de ces choses-là et
comprendre qu'on ne pourra pas être
libre et utiliser des ordinateurs
si l'on n pas une éthique et une
pratique stricte
de ce que l'on veut y voir et passer en
revue le matos, passer en revue le
software du début à la fin sans donner
les moyens aussi. l'hardware aussi.
Mais bien sûr. Mais alors là, tu parlais
de souveraineté tout à l'heure, c'est là
où les intérêts des individus rejoignent
peut-être les intérêts de ce qui reste
des États-nations
ou quand on on a vu que les États-Unis
ont interdit le hardware de Z et Huawei
parce qu'il y avait des bacs d'or des
Chinois dedans où Snowden nous a montré
que Cisco c'était rempli de bac d'or et
tout le monde utilise des routeurs
Cisco-Américains, donc à les Américains
au cœur de son réseau et cetera.
Si les gugus qui étaient dans les
ministères de la défense et les machins
et les anciules étaient pas en train de
se rouler les pouss était pas en train
de d'amener des contrats à Talè à Pal
ou à Palantir et avait quelque chose à
faire vraiment c'est les questions qu'il
faudrait se poser aujourd'hui et là on
pourrait imaginer des efforts au-delà
des nations, au-delà des budgets et
triqués des uns et des autres pour
commencer à réfléchir du hardware
vraiment sinon libre parce que là encore
c'est un concept machin mais du hardware
qui permettrait vraiment à ces
utilisateurs de savoir ce qui s'y passe.
Alors à avant que tu reprennes, il y a
une architecture de microprocesseur qui
s'appelle Risk 5 Risk RC comme reduced
instruction set he
qui est en fait une architecture de
microprocesseur en kit. Tu peux prendre
l'ensemble des specs ou un petit bout
des specs et faire ce que tu veux avec.
Tu as testé ?
Euh non parce que les premiers truc
risque risque 5 euh produit à quelques
je crois un millier d'exemplaires, il
valaiit 1000 balles la pièce. J'ai pas
encore eu ça entre les mains et puis
franchement moi je suis la dernière
personne pour aller de compiler des
machins là-dessus. Je connais des gens
10 fois plus balaises que moi pour faire
ces trucs là. Mais il se trouve qu'il y
a des gens dans le champ industriel avec
les milliards que ça implique qui sont
en train de se poser ces questions
aujourd'hui. Il y a un dégâts qui des
fondateur, je sais pas du tout en est le
projet, un des gars qui des fondateurs
du Raspberry P
qui a un gros succès mais qui au passage
est du hardware propriétaire avec des
puces de chez Broadcomi.
C'est pas une bague d'or mais c'est un
arc de triomphe de bac d'or au milieu de
ses Raspberry Pi. et lui a lancé un
nouveau projet en disant le but c'est
d'avoir du hardware qu'on ne peut
contrôler qu'avec du logiciel libre. Et
ça ça s'appelle low risque encore RC jeu
de mot. Risque risque.
Et ben peut-être que ça c'est un tout
petit pixel d'espoir
sur un gros tableau noir euh assez
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Tu te rappelles d'un are pote là
Estemman, ça te parle ? Tu sais qui
gueulait sur le le vernis de
vite fait. Ouais. Bon, on ferme la
parenthèse.
Euh donc il y a il y a il y a une vraie
question. Euh en gros, le logiciel
libre, ça va au-delà du logiciel.
L'informatique libre, ça va au-delà du
logiciel et se poser la question de ces
architectures
informationnelles qui permettent aux
individus
de vivre, d'exister, d'expérimenter et
de s'organiser
en en toute liberté.
plutôt que sous contrôle. Là, pour moi,
c'est un enjeu absolument
crucial. Et hélas, il y a peu de gens,
peu de ressources pour ces choses-là
aujourd'hui. Je pense que c'est un
combat qui Ouais. qui mérite vraiment
d'être mené.
Alors, question d'internet. Est-ce qu'il
peut nous dire un peu comment il
s'organise à à titre perso VPN tout le
temps, pas log et autres ?
Alors, il y a des
Il y av une autre question dans le même
sens. Vas-y.
Ouais.
Alors, une bon je suis pas le
Est-ce que Jérémy peut mettre en avant
des logiciels système moteur éthique et
social ?
Alors, pour ça, retrouvez-moi sur mon
blog Jérémy. Non. Euh, bon, il y a des
trucs que j'ai pas envie de révéler. Il
y en a, je suis vraiment pas un exemple
en tout. Oui, j'utilise un VPN pour
tout.
Qui est
euh C'est le VPN d'un ami.
C'est un ami qui commence par B. Non,
c'est un ami qui commence par ce qui ce
qui commence, c'est son truc. Euh c'est
lui. Voilà. Si je donne pas de nom,
c'est pas pour donner des lettres de
nom, tu vois hein. Parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui c'est pas comme Benjamin,
quoi.
Il y en a d'autres qui commencent par B,
tu vois. Et
hein, Bruno,
tu vois. Euh donc, j'utilise un VPN pour
tout, mais j'ai aucune illusion que ça
me protège de de quoi que ce soit. Euh,
j'utilise que des logiciels libres sur
mon laptop. Oui, donc j'ai pas un
firmware propriétaire, j'ai pas de
j'utilise pas le wifi de mon laptop.
J'ai enlevé la puce wifi de mon laptop
parce que celle-ci je pouvais pas
l'utiliser avec du logiciel libre.
J'ai un un BIOS en logiciel libre euh
qui s'appelle Coreboot.
Euh sur mon certains appellent encore sa
téléphone, mais sur mon ordinateur de
poche, j'utilise tant bien que mal un
truc qui s'appelle Replicant
qui est une version de Lineos qui est un
forc d'Android mais dans lequel il y a
aucun logiciel propriétaire. Donc j'ai
pas la caméra frontale, j'ai pas le GPU,
donc l'accélération hardware. J'ai pas
le Wii, j'ai pas le Bluetooth. Bon, ça
m'enlève des trous de sécurité au
passage hein. Mais c'est même pas une
question de sécurité parce que les mises
à jour de ce machin-là, c'est tous les à
savoir parce que c'est des volontaires
qui se crèvent la paillasse pour faire
ce truc. Donc, j'ai pas l'illusion que
ça m'apporte plus de sécurité. C'est
vraiment à la fois pour des raisons
éthiques et puis pour me mettre un peu
dans le bain pour savoir au jour le jour
euh ce que j'utilise et comment je
l'utilise. J'ai arrêté d'utiliser un
machin qui s'appelle Signal que beaucoup
d'activistes utilisent aujourd'hui qui
est une messagerie dite sécurisée.
Ben, j'ai arrêté de l'utiliser parce que
l'auteur Moxy a interdit aux gens de le
distribuer sans son autorisation et de
le distribuer autrement que par Google.
Donc la question est-ce que c'est
vraiment un logiciel libre ? pause, tu
dis mon truc c'est un logiciel libre.
Donc tout le monde a le droit de
l'utiliser, de le copier, de le modifier
euh et et de l'étudier. Mais si tu dis
ça et que tu dis au passage, au fait les
gens ont pas le droit de le modifier.
Bon, qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe vraiment ? Donc il y a ça, il y a
le fait que Signal t'oblige à donner ton
numéro de téléphone. Tu veux pas juste
avoir un nickname ou un machin jetable
dont tu es obligé d'avoir un numéro de
téléphone. signal centralise toutes les
métadonnées sur son infrastructure à lui
qui repose sur Amazon et sur Google et
au passage signale comme beaucoup de
projets qui sont dans le domaine de la
de la sécurité, de la protection de la
vie privée et cetera un financement en
grande partie par le gouvernement US.
Euh donc voilà, c'est pas pour
télégramme. Tel télégramme c'est une
farce. Enfin, moi j'en sais rien mais
mes potes cryptographes qui savent de
quoi ils parlent, il disent que la
crypto de Telegram c'est de la c'est de
la blague. Truc qui s'appelle wire qui a
l'air qui a l'air intéressant mais il y
a pas encore le code source de tout leur
appli espèce de gros veau machin. Il y a
rien qui soit parfait en la matière. Au
mocole
de chiffrement qui va avec Jabber qui
n'est pas OT et semble assez
intéressant. Mais tous ces machins c'est
presque du bricolage, tu vois. Je suis
pas en train de dire tout le monde doit
utiliser machin, tout le monde doit
faire comme moi parce que je me rends
bien compte qu'il y a encore énormément
de boulot et que ces trucs-là sont
difficiles. Maintenant, il y a un truc
sur le côté difficile d'accès, tu vois.
Et là aussi, ils ont fait des choix dans
leur interface.
Blip,
bip
blip
blip.
Ça parle pas. Même protocole que
Bitorent. En blip, ça me blip, ça me dit
rien. Euh signale, ils ont fait des
choix d'enlever de l'interface le fait
de vérifier la clé de chiffrement de ton
correspondant. Avant, dès que tu
ouvrirais un truc dans signal,
attention, le truc est pas vérifié.
Cliquez ici et puis tu allais voir
est-ce que c'est la bonne personne. Tu
passes un coup de fil, dis donc, c'est
bien toi 3 B 28. Et ben ça, il a enlevé
l'interface. Maintenant, il faut aller
dans menu claque bidule en bas option
claque, tu déroules en bas, tu cliques
vérifier. Ah oui, c'est bizarre ça parce
que si tu enlèves ça, ça rend plus
facile le fait de s'introduire dans les
communications de quelqu'un, même si
c'est chiffré, mais ils l'ont juste
pousser, pousser, poussé, pousser. Ils
l'ont poussé pourquoi ? Tu sais pourquoi
? pour rendre ça plus user friendly,
plus agréable, plus facile, plus simple
d'accès, un monde plus doux, plus
simple, plus joli, plus tout ça. Donc
moi de plus en plus j'ai l'impression
que penser l'informatique et l'usage des
ressources ordinateur réseaux tout ça en
terme de ce qui est facile et pas
facile, ce qui est confort et pas
confort, user friendly ou pas user
friendly, c'est en fait un piège
intellectuel
que quand quelqu'un te dit "Ah vas-y
clique ici, ça marche tout seul, c'est
user friendly" en fait il est en train
de t'arnaquer. Apple
par exemple, Apple par exemple, Google
par exemple, des exemples il y en a
plein. Et que penser que des outils
aussi complexes que les ordinateurs et
les réseaux qui les liit puissent être
simple, en fait c'est une erreur
intellectuelle et que de la même façon
qu'on va pas dire "Tu cliques ici pour
parler espagnol." Non, tu sais que tu
vas devoir passer quelques centaines
d'heures, voir quelques milliers
d'heures avant de parler l'espagnol.
Clique ici pour savoir jouer du violon.
Et ben non, c'est pas du violon, c'est
peut-être guitarro et quatre boutons,
mais c'est pas une vraie guitare.
Et tout le monde, personne va être
choqué à l'idée de se dire qu'il faut
passer des centaines d'heures avant de
savoir jouer de la guitare. Donc je dis
pas que chacun devrait passer des
centaines d'heures à apprendre
l'informatique avant d'utiliser
l'informatique,
mais le fait est que si tu prends pas le
temps d'essayer de comprendre et
d'utiliser des choses qui peuvent te
sembler un petit peu arides, et ben il y
a de très fortes chance que tu te fasses
arnaquer. Donc au lieu de penser en
terme de d'un côté user friendly et de
l'autre côté c'est trop compliqué parce
que tu comprends moi j'ai autre chose à
faire. On devrait plutôt penser en terme
de politique qui permet aux gens de
s'émanciper, de s'organiser et d'agir
librement versus une politique du
contrôle qui capture les gens, leurs
données et leur vie.
Est-ce que tu vois des choses à aborder
qu'on a des choses à aborder
des sujets qu'on a pas touché ? J'en
vois plein, j'envoie 1000 mais c'est ton
c'est ton job ici ?
Ouais non. Ouais. Bah il est 20h10 tu
sais donc
non je sais pas. Non qu'à la montre
c'est toi qui est mont.
On se on se tu vois un truc que tu veux
aborder avec nous ? Un sujet qui te qui
pourrait intéresser notre communauté.
Ben écoute sur les tu vas croire que
c'est ma marotte. Ah bah tiens, j'ai
qu'à faire un petit peu d'autopromo
parce que après mettre un peu crever le
cul pendant des années.
Donc tu es dans un film en ce moment
c'est ça ? Non, c'est pas ça.
après avoir fait des erreurs pour moi et
pour les autres en mode combien il faut
donner, combien il faut y aller, tu
sais, en bossant 7 jours sur 7 parce que
le weekend quand tu es pas en train de
te faire emmerder par des coups de fil
de journaliste, alors tu as le temps de
travailler pour ce qui doit arriver
lundi.
et que pareil après 8h du soir, c'est là
où tu peux commencer ta deuxième journée
de travail où tu peux être un petit peu
à l'abri des des sollicitation et
machin. Et donc après m'être cramé à la
tâche
euh après m'être cramé à la tâche et
après avoir directement ou indirectement
cramé des gens autour de moi, parfois
sans le vouloir mais parce que les gens
me couraient avec moi et que j'ai imposé
un rythme parfois trop dur.
Euh
je pense qu'il faut se poser la question
aussi de dans quand on combat euh les
combats peut-être que ça se fait en fait
jamais sans douleur,
tu vois. et donc d'apprendre à gérer
cette douleur et pas se dire que parce
que tu as 50 journalistes qui
t'appellent dans la journée, parce que
machin tout le monde te demande ton
avis, te dire que tu es une espèce de
superhéros qui va jamais mourir.
Euh mais réaliser le le la dureté, la
difficulté de ces combats-là et
s'organiser pour la gérer. Donc après ou
pendant plutôt mon burnout et le moment
dans ma vie où je me suis aperçu que mon
corps tout entier me demandait de tout
arrêter.
et où le il m'a fallait du temps pour
tout arrêter et la première chose que
j'ai recommencé à faire, c'est dormir
et me faire des nuit de 12h de 8h de
machin là où j'en étais à dormir 3 4
heur parit régulièrement parce qu'il y
avait tellement de choses à faire, tu
vois.
Et ben au moment où j'apprenais ça, je
réapprenais ça pour moi-même avec une
bande d'amis, on a créé un truc tout à
fait informel qui s'appelle hacking with
care.
Donc ça une espèce de jeu de mot. Donc
hacker au sens original, tu vois, de de
bidouiller hacker avec le K en même
temps hacker le K que l'on comprend
comme les façons que l'on a entre
humains de prendre soin les uns des
autres.
de partager de la de la bienveillance,
de la bonté et quelque part de voir ce C
comme autant de technologies que l'on
peut s'approprier, que l'on peut hacker,
que l'on peut partager. Moi, j'ai
énormément appris en massage. Cet
après-midi encore, j'étais en train de
faire le massage des pieds à une copine
qui est dans une phase difficile.
Euh, j'ai appris le massage des pieds et
mon amie masseuse, elle a appris la
cryptographie.
Et l'idée c'était de partager ses
compétences, de partager ces
technologies et c'est aussi bien le
massage que le yoga, que la méditation
euh que certains soins par les plantes
euh et de réfléchir ensemble à comment
on peut penser pour le coup vraiment en
dehors de la machine mais réfléchir à
l'humain en même temps que l'on
réfléchit à la société, à la politique,
au combat et cetera.
Un parti politique que tu soutiens ?
Non. Euh donc euh en même temps qu'on
faisait ce truc à King Whiscare, si tu
veux, on a on a commencé à produire des
ressources que chacun trouvera sur notre
wiki bien sûr, euh comme des protocoles
de massage, le massage des mains pour
tous, un petit livre qui ressemble au
fucking manual de read the fucking
manual que tu peux imprimer, laisser
traîner dans ton hackers space, dans ton
bureau avec tes copains et cetera et le
massage des mains comme un truc qui se
donne comme un cadeau et qui en même
temps crée un espace euh d'intimité.
dans lequel on se retrouve, dans lequel
on se parle, comment on se touche. Tu
vois, c'est un truc queon a perdu
l'habitude un peu de se toucher dans un
monde super individualiste.
peut trouver des espèces de canaux de
communication entre les individus.
Je pense que c'est directement connecté
à tout ce dont on a discuté sur la façon
de s'organiser, sur la façon de se
retrouver, sur la façon de reprendre le
contrôle de nos vies et plus se voir
comme des unités autonomes,
individualistes, randiennes,
performance, algorithmique et cetera,
mais comme des gens, des humains faits
de chair et dos, de force et de
faiblesse, de moments difficiles et
apprendre dans nos dans nos vies mais
aussi dans nos structures, dans nos
mouvements, dans nos modes
d'organisation à gérer ces descente, ces
moments difficiles et à pas dire "Ouais,
non, non, mais lui il est fou de toute
façon, de toute façon, lui c'est un
connard machin." Mais à à prendre soin
des autres, à s'ouvrir sur les autres,
je pense que c'est aussi une partie des
réponses. Donc, hacking with care les
uns les autres. Parti politique, non.
On arrive à la à la fin de notre
interview.
Il y a bien des questions d'internet
encore. Non, je sais pas. Ouais. Bah
alors internet qu'est-ce que vous foutez
internet ? Alors, est-ce que les
lanceurs d'alerte ne devraient pas
lancer proposer une nouvelle version du
système politique pouvoir écologie trois
points de suspension ?
Lanceur d'alerte proposé W.
Que pensent-il du néoludisme ? Un
mouvement moderne opposition à toute
partie du progrès technique ou
comment contribuer au développement du
logiciel ?
Tu vois qu'il y a des questions internet
? Merci Internet.
Y a-t-il pasout
Y a-t-il une taille critique sur chaque
structure
? W là tu tu me tu déjà là tu viens de
lancer trois questions qui en
contiennent chacune cinq. Euh
les cryptomonnaies
ou alors ça on laissera ça ceux que la
monnaie intéresse. Euh sur
sur la question des lanceurs d'alerte.
Non, c'est pas les lanceurs d'alerte qui
doivent faire des propositions. Les
propositions, elles doivent émerger de
de c'est c'est une vraie question de
comment on fait émerger des propositions
doivent émerger de partout à la fois et
admettre que les propositions sont
jamais consensuelles. Peut-être que ce
mythe de la démocratie représentative où
il faudrait quelque chose et 50,00 % de
suffrage exprimé parmi des votants qui
sont déterminés comme c comme c comme
ça. Peut-être qu'en fait, il faudrait
s'émanciper de ça et qu'une proposition
à partir du moment où elle a une masse
critique de soutien, alors elle devient
valide et peut-être qu'elle entre en
conflit avec d'autres propositions et
peut-être qu'il faut les expérimenter.
Mais les lanceurs d'alerte, non, c'est
pas une catégorie de population qui
serait au-dessus de tous les autres.
Maintenant, est-ce que au travers de
l'action du comme on dit le lançage
d'alerte, lancé d'alerte, est-ce qu'en
exposant
les les turpitudes, les mensonges, les
crimes des institutions
et des des entités qui sont censées être
les dépositaires d'une certaine forme
d'autorité,
de représentation et cetera, est-ce que
cette forme d'exposition là ne porte pas
en elle le le germe de proposition
C'est quelque chose de tout à fait
ouvert. Maintenant, il y a des solutions
techniques qui ont été avancées et tu
parle de cryptomonnaie machin, il y a
une espèce de technéatitude
qui a
blockchain
blockchain. Voilà. Ah ben tiens, la
démocratie ça marche pas. On a qu'à
faire une démocratie sur la blockchain
et ça va marcher. Right. Euh donc il y a
une forme de technéattitude. On nous a
dit oui Liquid démocratie machin, tu
vois, tu cliques ici. En fait le truc
c'est du vote électronique et le vote
électronique on sait que ça peut pas
marcher. Que quand tu as une machine qui
est entre l'expression de la volonté de
quelqu'un et un pouvoir quelconque, le
pouvoir il va aller mettre le doigt dans
la machine et la tourner à son avantage.
Euh donc j'ai pas il y a pas un truc
magique sinon ça ferait longtemps qu'on
l'aurait exprimé. Et c'est pas le fait
de d'ouvrir les entrailles euh des
institutions euh comme la NSA avec les
machins de Snowden. Euh c'est pas le le
fait d'exposer qui va magiquement
euh changer les institutions ou les
transformer en quelque chose de
meilleur. Maintenant, le fait d'exposer,
ça permet de faire réfléchir, ça permet
d'éveiller quelque part les consciences,
ça permet de donner des outil à chacun
se dire ou là ou là et de faire
peut-être ce petit pas de côté, de faire
ce ce petit pas de de de recul pour
prendre de la distance et se demander
comment comment on veut les choses.
Donc les lanceurs d'alerte, non, c'est
pas des c'est pas des héros non plus,
c'est à glorifier, à mettre sur un sur
un piédestal et cetera. On est
potentiellement tous des lanceurs
d'alerte. On a tous accès à des savoirs
plus ou moins exclusifs, plus ou moins
élitistes. Chacun dans sa boîte voit un
supérieur ou un collègue faire une
connerie et susceptible de dire à
d'autres qui sont pas dans le cercle,
qui sont pas dans le machin, là il se
passe quelque chose et il y a un vrai
problème. Tu vois, lancer l'alerte c'est
presque le le le devoir de chacun. Tu
vois, il y a pas quelques héros avec une
cape et un machin qui sont les lanceurs
d'alerte et le reste du monde des
alertes, il y en a plein qui
mérite d'être lancé. Euh la deuxième
question piège, c'était quoi ? Il y
avait pas
que pensent-il du néoludisme ? Un
mouvement moderne d'opposition
à tout tout partie du progrès technique
? Tout parti tout parti. Alors non,
s'opposer à tout de toute façon c'est
une stratégie perdante hein parce que
parce que tout t'arrive. Euh mais c'est
intéressant que ça vienne en ces
termes-là. Parce que le ludisme, c'est
un mouvement qui a souvent été décrit
comme des gens qui étaient contre les
machines et qui étaient contre le
progrès. En réalité,
c'est issu de mouvement très structuré
de de de travailleurs, d'employés qui
s'organisaient contre les abus de
pouvoir de leur patron. Des gens qui
s'organisaient contre l'exploitation
et qui ont vu les machines arriver comme
un outil de l'exploitation
et qui sont opposés aux machines comme
une des formes d'opposition à
l'exploitation. Donc le ludisme, c'est
pas juste des gens des crétins qui vont
aller casser les machines. C'est pas du
tout ça. C'est des gens qui ont eu euh
un recul et une analyse politique du
rôle des machines dans les interactions
entre les humains et qui ont dit si les
machines doivent être utilisées comme
ça, alors on ne veut pas les utiliser.
Ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
les Ludites ils ont été écrasés par
l'armée.
Ils ont tellement fait peur au pouvoir
en place. Parle-moi de boulon. Après,
c'est que on a envoyé l'armée écraser
les mouvements ludites pour dire à quel
point ils étaient perçus comme une
menace et peut-être pour dire à l'époque
combien le pouvoir en place était main
dans la main avec les industriels. Donc
l'histoire des Ludites, je crois que ça
en dit long sur l'histoire des
mouvements sociaux, sur l'histoire des
mouvements de résistance, sur l'histoire
des des mouvement qui conteste quelque
chose qui nous est imposé comme étant
c'est le progrès, c'est l'innovation,
donc on doit tous l'accepter. Allez hop,
tous une puce dans le cou, tous les
empreintes digitales, tous des caméras
partout, tous des machins. Des gens qui
vont dire "Non, non, attends, wait, on
on on souffle un coup, on réfléchit et
on se pose la question : "Est-ce qu'on
veut ça ? Oui ou non ?"
Donc je sais pas ce que nos amis les
internets entendent par néoludisme, mais
que qu'il y ait partout dans le monde et
dans tous les milieux euh et pas
seulement dans telle ou telle petite
niche politique, mais des gens qui se
posent aujourd'hui la question de notre
rapport aux machines,
de nos interactions avec les machines et
entre nous humains au travers des
machines et qui se demande s'il y a pas
peut-être une forme d'urgence à
reprendre le contrôle ou d'urgence à à
sortir de l'urgence.
Euh je pense que c'est quelque chose de
très sain.
Euh rapide bullrun.
Rapide bullrun.
Bon, Bullrun, c'est un des 150 et
quelques, je crois,
programmes de la NSA qui ont été exposés
par le petit nombre de documents
qu'Edward Snowden a en pratique rendu
public. Il y avait des tonnes, on en a
vu que très peu. Bullrun, c'est un de
ces programmes là. Il faut rappeler à ce
stade que on parle Stoden, Stoden,
Stoden. Stoden, c'est 2013 la
publication de ces documents et ces
documents étaient tous datés de 2012.
Donc c'était il y a 6 ans et 6 ans à
l'échelle de l'évolution des
technologies et à l'échelle de
l'évolution des des capacités des
ressources des services de
renseignement, c'est c'est c'est une are
plusieurs aires.
Donc bullrun c'était la capacité que
sarrogeait la NSA à aller
saboter
les technologies permettant de protéger
sa vie privée. Et bullrun c'était un
éventail de méthode pour aller saboter
les technologies. Parfois c'était placé
un employé de la NSA dans une équipe de
développement pour qu'il ajoute de trois
bugs que la NSA puisse exploiter pour
s'assurer qu'une technologie censée
protéger la vie privée la protège pas
tant que ça. Parfois, et ça a été encore
une fois documenté, c'était aller payer
10 millions de dollars une entreprise
RSA pour qu'elle laisse un trou de
sécurité ouvert au lieu de le corriger.
bullrun parfois ça a été des gens de la
NSA qui allaient s'asseoir dans les
comités de standardisation
des des protocoles pour dire "Oh là là,
ça l'air beaucoup trop compliqué le truc
que vous essayez de faire là. Non non,
on a un truc pour vous, c'est c'est plus
simple." Là encore pour permettre à la
NSA de se laisser un pied à l'intérieur
des protocoles, des communications, des
données et cetera. Donc ce que l'on
avait avec Bullrun, c'est sans doute là
encore une petite fenêtre sur cette
capacité-là, mais c'est une volonté des
États ou en tout cas des États-Unis et
de ses partenaires, les Five Eyes. Une
volonté des États,
les Five Eyes, c'est une une alliance
historique qu'il y a entre les
États-Unis, le Royaume-Uni, l'Australie,
la Nouvelle-Zélande et le Canada dans
lequel c'est leur service de
renseignement partage de l'information.
Donc on sait pas exactement ce qui
partage et comment. Mais en gros, on l'a
vu là aussi dans les dans les documents
d'Edor Stunden, le GCHQ britannique va
aller espionner des Américains parce que
la NSA officiellement a pas le droit
d'espionner les Américains et ensuite la
NSA va échanger l'espionnage d'un
citoyen Grand Breton contre ça. Donc
c'est c'est une espèce de marché de
dupe. C'est vraiment un marché pour le
coup, une espèce de jeu de poker où on
s'échange des des cartes. Et donc ce que
montre Bullrun, c'est que les États
investissent des ressources
considérables pour aller affaiblir
la capacité des individus et des
entreprises à protéger leurs données et
leur communication. C'est une c'est un
paradoxe immense parce qu'on le sait
cette agence, tu vois, c'est la NSA, la
National Security Agency, dont la
mission est de garantir, on indique la
sécurité nationale des États-Unis. Et
pour se faire, elle s'estime légitime
aller affaiblir la sécurité du monde
entier, y compris des citoyens
américains en rendant les protocoles de
communication, le matériel et cetera
plus faible, moins fiable.
On arrive à la fin.
Peut-être, c'est toi qui me dit.
Euh,
on dit toujours laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Ah merde,
il fallait t'en rappeler, mec.
On va on va te donner une préqu
donne deux trois livres à lire pour la
communauté et ensuite ton conseil pour
les jeunes génération.
Waouh
! Alors, il y en a un attends attends
attends, il y en a un. Bon, déjà, moi je
l'ai dit déjà, c'était à nos amis et
maintenant. Mais le troisème, si vous
arrivez à mettre la main dessus, théorie
générale de l'information et de la
communication de Robert Escarpite. Salut
Christophe, si tu nous regardes, euh un
ouvrage, je crois, de 1973
ou 16 qui est d'une densité, il faut
presque le voir comme une forme de de
poésie tellement ce truc est dense. Il y
a des équations et des machins. Et c'est
un un type qui é un scientifique
absolument brillant qui explique les
réseaux, qui explique les communications
et qui explique aussi le le pouvoir que
ça implique.
Un truc complètement visionnaire et
vraiment brillant. Après, peut-être des
trucs sur le sur le bouddhisme zen ou
sur le sur le taoïsme, mais j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de titre en tête.
Et conseil aux jeunes générations,
mais serait peut-être n'écoutez pas les
conseils des vieilles générations
et globalement ne leur faites pas
confiance.
Leur leur leur matériel, leur software,
leur protocole, leurs institutions.
Ayez toujours
un doute critique à leur sujet, y
compris ce que je vous dis là.
et et vraiment cultiver ce doute,
cultiver cette critique et
inventez-vous.
Inventez par
vous-même. Cherchez, essayer, échouer.
N'ayez pas peur d'échouer. Acceptez
l'échec comme une partie du chemin,
comme une partie de l'expérimentation
et surtout nous faites pas confiance.
Détrônez-nous, destituez-nous.
Jérémy Zimmerman. Merci. Merci à toi.
[Musique]